[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
Android design in action I'm your host
Roman Nurik and I am a butcher and in
today's episode we're going to talk
about ten more navigation anti-patterns
and when we say ten more each other
because we actually recorded a previous
episode of the show where we went into
ten of the most common UX issues user
experience issues that we saw and some
of those issues were specifically
related to navigation so in this episode
we'll talk about ten more navigation
anti-patterns that we've since kind of
thought about I guess since that episode
if you want to kind of talk a little bit
more about the background here yes Ari
of course and if you didn't catch a
previous episode and we kind of went the
background that part of our job is to
work the bunch of planners and look at
all kinds of applications out there and
can we come across all kinds of issues
and variations on the patterns some of
which works on which day one of the
things we often see is when people are
new to Android design they quickly think
of things like the visual language or
unquote but they sometimes don't
completely internalize the navigation
patterns and completely and grasp the
nuances of some of the consequences and
of tv18 from these plans so we wanted to
give you a benefit of both experience
and highlight some of the pitfalls we've
come across and we should watch out for
and what you can do instead exactly
alright without further ado let's get
started okay so ten more navigation
anti-patterns the first that we're going
to talk about is navigation in the
action bar overflow so this is getting
to be less and less common which is
great but the idea here is that you know
some of the apps that we've seen have
put their primary navigation so for
example home you know store my items you
know different categories browse things
like that basically kind of like the
core way to navigate your app they've
put this all into the action bar
overflow and
is really kind of the wrong place to
place to put your navigation their
number of reasons for this I mean the
most common I guess the the major reason
is that now most apps don't do this most
apps follow the guidelines and use more
standard UI patterns for exposing their
top-level navigation
well obviously talk about those things
like the navigation drawer things like
tabs really this is the wrong place to
put it
another reason is actually on older
devices that don't have the action bar
overflow it would be hidden under the
menu button and there are lots of issues
with with the menu button the hardware
menu button we won't get into all of
them today but this is definitely one of
the kind of the aunt one of the
navigation anti-patterns that we thought
was pretty common but you know luckily
it's getting less and less common
yeah Jerry it kind of goes against the
organization had a navigation on the
left and actions on the right and all
the other apps on the platform and
training uses look for so you know users
not finding sense actually apps and you
know if you fight is bad it could be
that you know they're just looking for
it elsewhere
so the second navigation anti-pattern
that we want to talk about today is
using UI patterns in the wrong order or
kind of having the wrong navigational
hierarchy so you know we have a couple
of you know major UI patterns for
exposing navigation things like the
navigation drawer the action bar spinner
and tabs action bar tabs or just regular
tabs so there's actually a pretty strict
ordering with how you should use these
in which order you should use them and
you know basically when you look at your
app in terms of its informational
hierarchy you'll you'll generally create
something like a tree right so the top
you'll have home at the second level
you'll have your major sections and then
with each section you may have
subsections and subsections and so on so
one of the things that we've actually
seen a handful of apps do is use these
different UI patterns to represent
different levels of that information
hierarchy now the wrong thing to do
would be to use say tabs to represent
the the top level and then the action
bar spinner to represent say
the next level and then for example the
navigation drawer to represent the third
or deepest level so this is actually
just kind of the wrong way to do it on
Android these three UI patterns actually
follow a pretty rigid level or pretty
rigid hierarchy so instead of doing
something like this the correct
hierarchy would actually be to always
have the navigation drawer represent the
topmost level of your application
hierarchy and then you know if you have
an action bar spinner that should be the
second level and finally if you have
tabs it should be a third level now if
you don't have a spinner if you just
have a navigation drawer and tabs such
as with Google Play Music then it would
just be the navigation drawer and then
tabs but really your tabs and your
spinner should never precede the drawer
the drawer always should represent the
topmost level of your application
hierarchy so this is a somewhat
contrived example that we have three
different levels of hierarchy of
navigation hierarchy in South Asia you
probably would generally want to avoid
that and perhaps you might do something
like having two levels of hierarchy in
your drawer or by a classical section
which we'll cover in its section and but
if you do have that kind of complex IRA
rocket and due respect this you
generally want to go for a top downwards
scan as the highest level you know that
is a natural mapping to the root of your
navigation and one thing can't wrinkle I
guess and as you'll see the drawer is
obviously underneath the action bar and
differently that when you open the
drawer the action bar is expected to
transform so in this instance you were
to get kind of only avoid an option so
in this case you the spirit would
disappear you'd probably just have the
application name itself and any action
that's not relevant to the entire
application should disappear from that
and so yeah only further top-down
approach you'll be okay and another
thing with the drawer is that we did
have another episode specifically about
using the navigation drawer as and we
had believe rich Fulcher and Jen's Nagel
from the Android design team that talked
a little bit about you know how to use
the drawer and in which cases it's most
useful so definitely take a look at that
episode if you have more questions about
using the drawer
okay with that let's move on absolutely
so the next panel that we want to cover
is talking about and taps so times in
Android have a very high strong and
mental link to horizontal swipe so
whenever you see tabs you kind of
absolutely expect to be able to
horizontally and swipe between content
so for that reason if you do have some
kind of a generative content and you do
want to be careful about and putting
that within tabs because you gotta have
some swipe ambiguity lock you know you
when you see a tab you expect to be able
to swipe to change between not to leave
the content within it so one thing to
add here is that if it's a part of the
tab it's maybe like a small section
that's swipeable let's say you have you
know horizontally scrolling photo
gallery or something like that if it's a
part of the tab and it's generally okay
you know it's there are cases where it's
possible to kind of do this it's just
the issue here is that the entire tab
contents are another left and right
swipe region and so it creates this kind
of ambiguity between am i swiping
between tabs or am i swiping between
pages in cases like if you have a map
where it's not really swiping between
pages you're kind of panning a surface
it's it's also okay but it's again
something that you may want to rethink
because there will be that ambiguity but
in this case I mean this is just kind of
one of those textbook cases I guess of
ambiguity kind of really you know
messing messing with the standard
Android pattern or standard Android
interaction of tabs being directly
linked with their content so instead of
doing this another way to I guess solve
solve this issue is to instead of doing
horizontal paging you can kind of do a
vertical scrolling type thing for the
tab contents so basically any time you
have nested horizontal swiping really
try to think is there a better way to
present this maybe it's breaking out the
content into a separate screen maybe
it's using a different interaction
vertical scrolling versus horizontal
paging but really kind of think about
that because that is something that can
create that ambiguity
so the next anti-pattern we're going to
talk about is deep or persistent tabs
these often go hand-in-hand so first let
me talk about deep tabs when we say deep
tabs we really talk about I guess we
compare deep versus shallow tabs on
Android tabs should be shallow what that
means is that there shouldn't be too
much navigation within tabs maybe you
have like a view switch like you like
change the sort order or something or
something like that or maybe you have
you know scrolling and whatever but you
really shouldn't have any sort of
hierarchy or history within the tab what
that means is you know in this example
let's say you're looking at the contents
of a tab and you select one of these
grid items you shouldn't you should take
the user to a new screen you shouldn't
actually take the user or update the
contents of the tab with whatever you
just clicked on and then when you press
back and I would go back here this is
not something you want to do this is
actually something we would call a deep
tab a tab that has hierarchy or history
and so you know the reason for this I
guess is that first of all this is just
kind of a platform norm this is not
something that's generally done in
Android but the second thing is that you
know what happens when you swipe to
other tabs or switch between different
tabs you actually leave your tabs in all
sorts of weird states and the the
behavior of when you what happens when
you get back to that tab isn't really
well-defined I mean should you reset the
tab back to its top level should you you
know stay where it is you really kind of
don't want to have too much state going
on this is actually a recurring theme
when your app has too much state that
the user has to keep in mind or can be
onyx or too much state that may be
unexpected to the user that's going to
result in kind of confusion so the
things you want to avoid and so for that
reason we generally consider tabs as
shallow on Android another similar point
here is persistent tabs so persistent
tabs are basically tabs that behave like
global navigation that are always there
throughout your app and so you know the
problem with this and they can either be
on the top or the bottom when they're on
the bottom that's even worse because
again
Android should be at the top but
persistent tabs regardless of where they
are are problematic because you know
they that's not really how global
navigation should work on Android
especially with things like the back
button you know what happens when you
switch between tabs and then kind of you
know do stuff within tabs the back
button behavior is no longer really
well-defined and so it's it's not really
a platform norm as well as kind of you
know there's a lot of confusion that
will result from it to have tabs that
are persistent across across the app and
for that reason you know one of the
reasons that we created the navigation
drawer was to allow apps to create these
kind of global context switch type UI
patterns or you is where you know it's
switch between you know some deep part
of one section to a whole other section
of the app you can use the navigation
drawer which is available through an
edge swipe so really I guess the
summarize is very long-winded argument
avoid persistent tabs that are there
throughout and avoid deep tabs basically
two tabs that have hierarchy anything to
add Nick before I move on very well okay
let's do it I'm going to talk about
actually real quick yeah if that's this
right we had some examples of ways to
mitigate this so in this previous
example you had your tabs you know show
the contents of the thing you just
clicked on in this next example instead
of showing the tabs you basically take
the user to a whole new screen with a
whole new action bar and an up character
an UP button and then to get back to
where the user just was they would just
press the UP button and then of course
if you have a navigation drawer you can
always expose it here through an edge
swipe so that's deep and persistent tabs
if you want to talk about back
traversing across tabs yeah absolutely
says rumor saying having these kind of
shadow tabs we also consider moving
between tabs to be kind of a very
lightweight action it's not something
that's going to actually drop history as
it will drop something into your kind of
navigation history and so therefore the
back button should not unwind
and you're moving between tabs like this
so in this example here if you're on the
third tab anywhere to kind of tap or
swipe between them and tapping tapping
Bashan and one key in fact if you can
embrace the fact of having swipe between
it but feel pretty unnatural for a top
of a Batman 2 & Windus flight button and
so that's one of the reasons why we say
not to do that exactly and a similar
area where you shouldn't wear the back
button shouldn't do maybe what you you
think it should do is when you're when
you're changing between different drawer
sections so for the drawer you know you
may think if I switch from section 1
section 3 to section 4 you know pressing
back should switch between those but
actually the the platform standard here
again for the back button is to is
basically when you switch between
sections in the drawer you should
actually reset your task stack it's
almost like you you've entered in a
different app and that's really what you
know what the navigation drawer is good
for if you look at an example like
Google+ for example the Google+ app when
you switch between different sections
you're almost entering different apps
and the navigation drawer is really good
at you know at these types of scenarios
but really kind of the guidance here is
when you switch between sections in the
drawer you should you know the pressing
back should probably either kick you out
of the app or you know if your users are
getting confused by why is this leaving
the app it should maybe take you to the
topmost section so for example home so
if I go between home and you know browse
and search and store and categories
pressing back from categories should
really only take me back to home and
then to the home screen or just the home
screen anything bad next before we move
on it's a really powerful way I think is
if you do have one natural in one place
which you always expect users to want to
come in on and probably get back to it
very easily it's okay to have one level
of back items
it is that you know fresh towel stack
and to take them back through that so
they have that stability of really
easily going back to that natural kind
of home position from a subsection
exactly otherwise yeah kind of treat
changing sections similar Spanish
changing to house it's not a vicious
bear then all right let's move on
deepa navigations origin you want to
cover this one Nick yeah next one is one
of my pet hates is it's probably as
smell really that and if you have to do
this down here of having deep navigation
structures in your drawer it probably
means your your code navigation needs to
be simplified somewhat and make as
broken up into you know different
sections or different applications
perhaps or something like this and but
the idea of the navigation drawer is
it's a stable list of navigation targets
which you can always kind of and get to
and jump between stuff and you don't
want to put any kind of cognitive load
on the user to actually remember where
they were or where kind of gone through
and it must be a stable favor when I
open up the drawer I know I can like you
know I have my how much and I have
whatever option to navigate to so you
want to avoid having different steps or
I've even seen like secondary drawers
popping up from a first drawer which is
also pretty crazy as here do do try and
avoid this and an alternative we're
actually having some kind of like
subsection behavior I think we hinted at
this earlier on it is okay to have these
kind of expand all items and the reason
this is kind of a case because it's not
this huge context which you're not kind
of completely replacing the contents of
the drawer with sewing new and forced
into users can keep keep up with where
they are in there are two but it's just
kind of an in-place expand which shows
the user slightly more options so that
we can I think is cool and we have a
little bit more guidance on what touch
the exact touch targets should be
exactly how they should behave in the
design guide so if you go to developer
danger that calm starts design slash
patterns slash navigation - drawers that
HTML I think it is
we're just searching for navigation
drawers Android design you will see some
more details about exactly how this
should behave basically each line item
should actually have to touch targets if
section one has its own landing screen
but anyway there's an another
alternative if you wanna talk about that
one sure yeah so an alternative might be
instead of like putting all your
navigation to draw and you might break
up to another kind of way of doing cell
navigation so in this example on screen
here we're kind of in this the screen
you kind of get you when you switch
sections you can have some kind of one
application type activity there as well
as content or as we talked about earlier
and you combine another navigation
pattern so for example you might use the
draw of your major navigation sections
and then use a spinner perhaps for kind
of sub sections of that so you know
don't feel like just because you were
using the draw that you have to have all
your navigation and kind of like force
right into that in the same place if you
get out other ways to to allow that
subsection navigation in a good example
that again is Google Play Music when you
go into its a drawer you see things like
listen now and in my library under my
library you see things like artists
genres and so on that could have been in
the drawer but that was actually placed
into tabs the nice thing about tabs you
can actually really quickly swipe
between those different subsections
so definitely think about different ways
to do this one thing I should mention
here is we specifically called out you
know content one content two and these
little wire frames because you don't
want to just have purely navigational
elements on here even you know you
should add a little bit of content to
the screen you don't want it to turn
into a dashboard type thing we just see
a bunch of big icons or a bunch of big
text blocks and you know one of the ways
you could do that obviously is to show
content on others to just show images
you know show dynamic images
representing that section I think an
example of that is Google Play newsstand
I don't remember off the top of my head
but definitely don't don't just throw
text on the screen that's a little sad
yes Emma anybody's that's exactly
alright
our eighth item here is bad drawer
transitions so there are a couple of
things that this involves when we say
transition we both mean the animation
the actual visual change as well as
kind of the the transition from one
screen that has a drawer to another
screen that doesn't actually I think
that the next two items are related to
this but basically when you let's say
you're in you open up the drawer and you
touch section one you shouldn't actually
be taken to a new screen with an up
caret basically there's this strong
guidance that says anything any screens
that are represented in the drawer so
for example here section 1 section 2
section 3 and so on
when you actually get to those screens
they should also show a show the drawer
indicator so the first issue here that
you don't actually see the drawer
indicator you see this up caret instead
so that would be incorrect
but another I guess slightly more subtle
aspect of this is the transition when
you you know go between section 1 and
section 2 you shouldn't see the standard
default zoom up transition that takes
you to a new or that that you see when
diving into like you know into content
or showing a new activity showing a new
screen you should first of all try to
suppress that transition so it should be
really fluid it's almost like you know
you touch something the drawer closes
and then the the content of the section
you just selected just kind of fades in
or appears it shouldn't be this jarring
kind of zoom up animation that changes
the action bar and does all this stuff
another thing to think about I guess
more for developers is and this is a
question we get all the time is should I
have a multiple activity or multiple
fragment app when I'm using the drawer
and there's no easy answer there's no
right answer it really depends on the
situation so if you guys have I guess
suggestions for the developers out there
feel free to comment my suggestion would
be just kind of examine the difficulties
and you know whether or not it makes
sense for your app I would I think by
default start with multiple activities
with you know replacing the transition
but having a like a single activity with
multiple fragments that is possible as
well okay shroo move on yeah we just got
a good example yes and it was only that
every section
which is pairs in the drawer you expect
at the draw affordance and shown on the
screen and other sections it should show
you okay yeah so related to that is
never showing the up caret and this is
really kind of the converse of that or
the inverse of that whatever it is you
should so like we said anything that is
represented in the drawer should show
the drawer indicator but things that
aren't represented in the drawer for
example here we're looking at a specific
piece of content we've now you know
dived into or douve into a specific news
story for example at this point the
drawer indicator shouldn't be there you
should instead show the up caret because
you're now in kind of a deeper section
or a deeper part of the app within one
of the sections in the drawer and so you
know instead of instead of doing like
this something like this should
obviously show the up caret but what you
can do to still expose the drawer is
allow an edge swipe and again this is
something that's in our in our
documentation in our design guidelines
it doesn't you don't necessarily have to
show the the edge or the v3 little line
indicator the navigation drawer
indicator to have a drawer in this case
having the drawer there is more kind of
like a power user feature for folks that
discover that gesture great for those
that don't you know that's that's not so
great but they always have that ability
to navigate to those other sections by
pressing up so you're not necessarily
you're not really keeping functionality
from a certain class of users you're
really just kind of adding additional
functionality for power users I guess is
kind of two competing things like
compute the same space we want the user
to have the hierarchical navigation to
have that strong sense that it's going
to keep you wearing it within the app
and go to a parent type screen so you
want the happy hour care act and well I
draw one of the great facilities with
the drawers that you can have it
available to you elsewhere to do these
cross-cutting navigation gestures and so
I'd like to resolve those two kind of
competing computing themes is CI showing
up Cara O'Malley and the edge gesture
and an interesting kind of
implementation detail I guess
is what you do when you saw images edge
- I have the draw over and I think a
really nice way to do this is if you
take a look at the way people play new
standards this is I'll show the up caret
and as you an edge swipe out the draw
they'll cross pay the end of the carrot
into the open drawl or kind of
affordance so it makes sense that when
you kind of look at the screen earlier
that's the door open I know that
touching that's gonna close it or when
you have content screen you have a floor
let's give you the stability of an
expectation of navigation exactly true
move on to our last anti-pattern yeah 10
do you want to have this one Nick yeah
for sure so the last I'm gonna pick out
is using kind of right side navigation
we touched on this slightly at the top
of the show there's a strong strong kind
of an organizational feelin and going to
have navigation activities on the left
and actions on the right a case with
most kind of left-to-right languages you
scan the page in one way and it kind of
reinforces a hierarchy that this is kind
of your navigation your I rock you kind
of you top-level things and then content
and being on the right-hand side and so
if everything I say on this example here
we're showing a tableau which has kind
of a larger screen it's been and
available to it to show so we can
assistant li and so you wouldn't want to
put that on the rise I do want to keep
that left aligned to go with that
general organization now on the Left yep
so basically here's the bad screenshot
here's a good screenshot this really
works with both navigation you shouldn't
have navigation drawers on the right as
well as a master-detail scenarios you
shouldn't have the master on the right
you should really have master on the
left it should really read left to right
and obviously an RTL locales like I
guess in fear languages in Hebrew or
Arabic this would be flipped yes he's a
crafty Stalin and left and right
examples so those are the 10 more anti
patterns for navigation that we wanted
to talk about today
I guess it's both kind of navigation and
app structure if you will if you have
any more anti patterns if this wasn't
kind of well this obviously wasn't a
comprehensive exhaustive list but if you
have any more anti patterns that you
want to share feel free to you know
let us know in the comments or just post
something to Google+ with the hashtag
hash Android dev and we'll take a look
and possibly comment
so with that thanks again for joining
Android design in action as always I'm
your host Roman Nurik and thanks for me
bitchin see you guys next time